[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur TV 78 pour un
nouveau numéro du VIP le magazine où
nous recevons un yvelinois qui en soit
originaire ou qui vivent encore
aujourd'hui une fois n'est pas coutume
je vais demander à notre réalisatrice de
ne pas montrer tout de suite notre
invité puisqu'on va d'abord l'entendre
et vous allez vite comprendre pourquoi
bonjour salut un petit mot
supplémentaire
une grande invitation implique de grande
responsabilités ça devrait à peu près
poser les bases alors j'imagine qu'on
est peut-être est en train de se dire
qu'on vous avez déjà entendu cette voix
mais où quand alors personnellement
c'est une voix que j'entends depuis mon
enfance n'ont pas parce qu'il a un grand
âge parce qu'on est de la même
génération c'est Donald de réunion qui
est avec nous bonjour bonjour
première surprise Titeuf il a grandi
dans les Yvelines
ça a été une surprise je l'ai appris
pour par rapport à un stream VF on a
commencé avec Titeuf cette voix c'est
vous qui l'avez trouvé
n'importe quoi mais j'avais envie de
m'amuser et puis surtout j'avais envie
de proposer quelque chose de d'inédie
donc c'était cool
on arrive toujours à faire cette voix
ouais mais la voix a bougé c'est que là
celle que je viens de faire par rapport
à 2001 là le film ce qu'on voit en élu
c'est c'est cette voix là mais la voix a
bougé parce que j'ai commencé j'avais 19
ans là moi j'aimerais 40 oui donc la
voix elle a évolué au fur et à mesure
des épisodes donc forcément
elle change mais maintenant ça fait
quelques années que les gravés dans le
marbre ça va et vous voulez retrouver
facilement
bon je pense qu'en régie ça doit
j'ai mis un petit peu alors vous êtes la
voix de Titeuf mais pas que la liste
elle va être non exhaustive bien sûr
parce que la page wiki comme vous faites
dans stream VF il y en aurait pour des
heures
entre Garfield Jesse Eisenberg
Spider-Man Harold dans Dragon Andy dans
Toy Story des publicités vous êtes si
vous officiel de la radio NRJ avec
Richard d'Arbois excusez du peu je vais
m'arrêter là parce que c'est pas moi
qu'on écoute parler aujourd'hui comment
vous êtes tombés dedans par hasard une
amie de ma mère qui cherchait des
enfants pour pour pouvoir faire des
chansons dans un premier temps il
refusait de me prendre pour pas me
pistonner mais j'en ai marre de voir
tout le temps mes potes y aller et pas
moi et
Malcolm de grands souvenirs mais en fait
chacun ses petites madeleines de Proust
donc
un personnage dont on vous parle pas
souvent le docteur archimoriste
ça fait partie des doublages qui m'ont
beaucoup formé mais mais ouais c'est
vrai que en tout cas voilà c'est ça
c'est que je suis tombé dans le petit
par une un petit coup de pouce mais j'ai
entretenu cette chance et mais j'en
faisais pas une un objectif et le
doublage avait pas la la la la
visibilité qui a maintenant
mais c'est vrai que c'est cool ça
parcours quand même atypique et puis par
le chant et pourtant vous chantez pas
souvent je crois que ça part la Reine
des Neiges 2 c'est vrai que c'est pas
mon fort le chant ça me permet d'avoir
des rôles souvent chez Disney parler
chanter mais je suis pas proprement
parler chanteur parce que je suis pas je
n'entends pas les capacités donc en
comédien je suis capable de proposer 10
versions différentes par prise et qui
ont rien à voir en change je suis
capable de chanter juste ça s'arrêtera
là donc je peux pas interpréter plus que
que ça on est arrivé presque à
aujourd'hui mais au début vous dites des
chants des bois additionnels et le
premier rôle vous tapez quand même très
fort Andy Toy Story
ce n'est pas le premier rôle mais en
tout cas c'est le premier vrai rôle qui
m'a lancé effectivement
c'est vrai que le bouche-à-oreille après
ce film là a été énorme et voilà vu
qu'on est dans les Yvelines j'étais au
collège Mozart et j'ai arrêté le collège
traditionnel le jour de l'avant-première
pour partir en cours par correspondance
et il m'avait dit que que c'était pas un
métier de faire comédien donc
je peux comprendre c'est un métier qui
est qui est précaire moi je m'en sors
très bien et qui est très hasardeux mais
c'est vrai que on peut très vite avoir
des des longs moments sans travailler
donc je peux je peux comprendre qu'ils
étaient inquiet mais je suis content
d'avoir eu raison de croire en moi et
les copains au collège à l'époque je
m'en cachais parce que je sentais déjà
que là il y avait un petit peu de
jalousie donc j'ai la fin j'avais dit
que j'avais arrêté et il y a un moment
donné voilà quand on est Story est
arrivé là j'ai fait bon là on s'arrête
quoi qu'est-ce qui vous plaît dans ce
métier parce que finalement comédien
spécialisé dans le doublage vous êtes
plus
de intéressant des rôles que j'aurais
jamais pu tourner enfin là quand je fais
le grand méchant dans Batman ou le
Spider-Man ou une série rôle principal
pour Disney plus et puis des animations
pour Netflix jamais j'aurais fait ça aux
États-Unis j'aurais jamais j'aurais fait
ça en France en tournant donc je peux
être que honoré et et content de de
pouvoir avoir des rôles comme ça en
doublage et
moi ce que trouve mes potes dans le
théâtre ou dans les tournages moi je le
trouve dans ben voilà dans les émissions
que je peux animer aussi ou les streams
ma petite adrénaline quand on me fait
mon décompte avant l'émission j'ai le
générique qui va et on n'est pas
enregistré je sais que quoi qu'il se
passe Montréal il lance l'émission cette
adrénaline qu'on trouve au théâtre moi
je l'ai en émission donc voilà je trouve
je trouve ce ce côté là fun de dans
d'autres moments que les autres
comédiens notamment stream VF votre
émission on en parlera un petit peu tout
à l'heure on en voit quelques quelques
images
ce qui est saisissant quand vous faites
du redoublage c'est la rapidité avec
laquelle vous vous saisissez parfois de
textes ou d'improvisation
improbable je n'aimerais même pas
Christophe Lemoine
comment c'est parce que c'est l'habitude
ouais c'est une gymnastique c'est sûr
que aujourd'hui on peut on peut arriver
si on veut à doubler des épisodes sans
regarder la VO les les deux secondes de
temps que la bande rythme donc le texte
qui défile et qui passe devant la barre
entre le début et le moment ça passe
dans la barre avec l'habitude on a le
temps d'anticiper l'humeur ce qui se
passe à l'écran et d'être quasiment tout
le temps dans l'émotion de qui a à faire
et c'est invisible pour le spectateur
tellement le on a mangé des épisodes de
dessins animés des trucs comme ça vous
fallait une rapidité d'exécution donc
ouais c'est ça demande d'être hyper vif
et j'adore ça
est-ce que on vous rattache à une voix
en particulier vous disiez chacun à sa
madeleine de Proust selon les
générations mais ce qui a une voix ou
quand on vous croise dans la rue on se
dit ouais c'est Spider-Man c'est
Spider-Man
quelque chose de global entre les jeux
les pubs les films des petits des petits
feats dans les dessins animés dans les
vidéos YouTube pour pour des
influenceurs ça c'est un truc global et
que c'est cool parce que je suis fan du
personnage aussi donc c'est c'est très
sympa mais comme c'est ma voix normale
on me reconnaît là dessus mais quand je
vois dans les conventions on parle tout
le temps de spidier en premier mais de
Titeuf de dragon de Malcolm d'autres sur
Kingdom Hearts un jeu vidéo où il y
avait une VF à l'époque donc c'est
chacun une vision différente mais ceux
qui reviennent le plus c'est cela
vous expliquer maintenant que la voix de
Reese dans Malcolm est autant marquée
vous arrivez sur la saison 3 vous aviez
pas totalement mué à l'époque comment
après tout moi c'est vraiment une des
c'est à ce moment-là peut-être avec
aussi chalaboeuf sur la guerre des
Stevens ou votre voix m'a le plus marqué
enfant
ouais c'est des séries qui ont regardé
la télé quand on sortait de du collège
et tout ça où il s'était Récept était
sympa
et la série était totalement barrée elle
était hyper bien réalisée c'était hyper
drôle et du coup elle est restée sur des
années c'est si je crois que j'ai jamais
vu une série autant rediffuser que
Malcolm c'est incroyable et vous amusiez
autant que pouvait peut-être s'amuser
les comédiens parce que vous avez des
situations improbables dans la série
nous ça va un peu vite c'est un peu
comme quand on fait Game of Thrones je
suis pas dedans mais j'imagine très bien
la situation c'est qu'on fait sa partie
on voit pas les autres parties donc moi
la partie Francis quand il est dans le
rangeais pas parce que j'aurais jamais
ce que je fais donc mal comme je le
connais très mal finalement la série
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
je voyais pas tout le côté comique mais
le peu que je voyage je voyais que
c'était un truc de fou mais je m'en
rendais pas compte de la chance qu'on
avait et que c'était un ovni etc une
pépite donc j'aurais dû le plus le
savourer à ce moment là mais bon
malheureusement c'est fait est-ce que
vous avez des comédiens fétiches aussi
j'avais entendu parler de chez Eisenberg
ou d'andrugerfield est-ce que ça l'est
toujours est-ce que ça évolue
Garfield et jessemberg sur un pied
d'égalité alors j'ai beaucoup plus fait
en droguerfield ces derniers temps donc
j'ai la plus tendance à le mettre en
chouchou mais l'année dernière j'aurais
mis Jesse Eisenberg en premier mais là
Paul Dano je commence à beaucoup le
doubler en ce moment donc tout à fait et
aussi le le Spielberg qui arrive là j'ai
fait la bande-annonce mais c'est c'est
cool c'est des déroule en or mais
j'adore cette comédiens ils sont pas
évident à apprivoiser
alors on en a parlé vite fait on a vu
quelques images vous avez une chaîne
Youtube twitch vous échangez avec
d'autres comédiens spécialisés dans
doublage alors là où s'il est non
Emmanuel Curtil costantin pas passe
Benoît dupac Mike Dara je pourrai pas
tous les citer le non plus ça a beaucoup
de succès comment vous l'expliquez parce
que voilà là vous donnez le nom des
comédiens et je suis sûr que 99%, ça pas
qui on parle et pourtant là on parlait
de Whoopy Goldberg Jim Carrey du nain
dans Game of Thrones de voilà il s'est
Benoît dupac qui fait qui fait Onizuka
dans dans GTO qui est aussi le le
directeur artistique de tout le Walking
Dead donc du coup on le fait ah oui
d'accord je comprends mieux donc du coup
ça attise la curiosité on se dit ah mais
non du coup on connaît pas sa tête donc
ça fait du bien de voir sa tête et de
pouvoir mettre une un visage sur sur une
voie et
donc du coup nous ça permet d'avoir des
anecdotes et je le dis souvent en
émission mais on parle dans l'émission
de choses auxquelles on n'a jamais parlé
dans les studios
partag votre univers complètement donc
c'est un mix de curiosité du public et
de deux mois aussi donc c'est sympa je
j'ai vraiment eu des anecdotes de fou
dans cette émission j'aurais jamais
imaginé quoi oui
Martin qui a rencontré
deux fois où Samuel Jackson qui était à
table d'à côté il dit non mais viens
viens manger avec nous ok super
incroyable
tout à l'heure de bois d'artistes vous
avez toujours des attaches parce que
vous arrêtez le collège
pas trop
j'ai quelques voilà sur les réseaux des
on a gardé quelques connexions mais j'y
reviens que rarement mais c'est un c'est
une région que j'aime bien peut-être
qu'il retournait un jour mais c'est vrai
que j'ai pas mal écumé la règle alors on
est un peu pris par le temps je pense
qu'on pourrait parler avec vous pendant
des heures je suis pas sûre que votre
agenda vous me permettez qu'on termine
sur autre chose que le cinéma il y a pas
que ça dans votre vie vous êtes aussi
passionné juste en mécanique et de jeux
vidéo en 2019 vous êtes nommé capitaine
de la team Forza c'est l'équipe eSport
de la célèbre marque automobile et vous
présenter des émissions spécifiques
notamment Racing stream avec Arnold sa
mère qui est un ancien défi aussi
il est passé par l'ufq juste en face de
mon studio Déclic Théâtre
j'ai fait un VIP avec lui aussi vous
faites de la moto avec Alexis Thomas
aussi je commente les championnats du
monde qui sont qui sont fait très
récemment à Monaco et ouais c'est c'est
quelque chose qui m'a jamais quitté que
voilà j'ai beaucoup développé sur le sur
les routes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de la 12 la 13
voilà c'est le premier amour non mais
ouais c'est j'ai eu ça toujours couler
dans mes veines et je suis content de
pouvoir mixer les jeux vidéo là les
médias et tout ça ensemble c'est trop
cool quoi
ça fait des journées bien remplies mais
ouais c'est j'aime toucher à tout je
suis curieux et j'aime bien avoir plein
de casquettes différentes quoi on est
vraiment vraiment pris par le temps dans
l'oreillette on dit qu'il faut conclure
un petit regret mais alors quel est
votre actualité
je suis dans ce moment doublage dans la
grosse série d'animés donc les ados je
pense connaissent tous ça s'appelle
chainsoman
qui passe sur Crunchyroll et puis et
puis voilà pour début 2023 retour de
stream VF avec plein de nouveaux
concepts sur la chaîne Youtube mais
toujours dédié au doublage et puis la
chaîne Youtube de Titeuf qu'on a démarré
sur le qui a sa propre chaîne qui joue
avec des influenceurs et que on va
vraiment booster pour 2023 donc
ouais on pourra en faire 4-5 des VIP là
on a encore des choses à dire une belle
relation avec Titeuf notamment sur
Twitter on va passer quelques vidéos
merci beaucoup donaldo d'avoir accepté
votre invitation c'était un plaisir de
vous recevoir sur ce plateau le film
bien sûr c'est terminé ça revient très
bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]